scp-096 versus the m134 minigun the  world's fastest machine gun who would  win the m134 minigun is a truly  terrifying piece of tech capable of  firing around six thousand seven point  six two millimeter rounds per minute  often eliminating even the hardiest of  targets but what about scp-096  well as we have learned from some of the  other mind-blowing videos on our channel  if there is a way to defeat the shy guy  conventional arms fire certainly isn't  it the scp foundation has fought 096  with heavy machine guns on a number of  occasions and on some of these the  bullets didn't even slow the monster  down if you see this beast's face we're  sorry to say that even the m134 minigun  will not save you go watch our 096  videos now and see for yourself